well Israel's military has apologized
after one of its tanks mistakenly hit an
Egyptian border post near Gaza it says
it's investigating what happened
Egyptian authorities say nine people
have suffered minor
injuries well the Israeli Army also says
it's hit at least 320 Targets in Gaza
over the past 24 hours they include a
tunnel housing Hamas Fighters and dozens
of command and out and Lookout posts it
also struck what it said were mortar and
missile launchers positions well let's
bring in Andreas cre he is a senior
lecturer in security studies at Kings
College London he joins me now live from
there Andreas we know there have been
ground skirmishes inside Gaza over the
last day or so between Hamas and Israeli
soldiers one soldier we know was killed
IDF soldiers have been into Gaza before
do they know what to expect
now all yeah it's it's difficult to say
uh what they can expect because nothing
has ever been done on that scale uh this
is an unprecedented war in terms of the
extensity and the urban environment that
they're operating in couldn't be any
more difficult I mean loads of people
trying to make uh you know using for
metaphors and trying to compare this to
anything that we've done in modern war
that we've seen in Modern Warfare in
terms of urban combat and I I I suppose
it's worse than anything that we've seen
pretty much since the second world war
and I'm saying that because not only are
you operating in a confined Urban space
but you're operating in a space where
where there is an overground and there
is an underground with some of the
tunnels being concrete reinforced 70 M
deep difficult to penetrate and where
Israel can't really use its full uh
agility of its military as well as its
numerical superiority against Hamas
Fighters there will be ambushes there
will be traps um so it is an extremely
difficult situation and even if you had
a whole out you know combined arms sort
of approach towards Gaza I don't see how
uh Israeli soldiers can really advance
in achieving any of their objectives
there well given that we've been hearing
about this potential ground offensive
for some time now and it appears to have
been laed somewhat how prepared are both
sides for it to take
place well there is a there's an
operational preparedness but the
question is to what extent are you
mentally prepared to actually take and
sustain the the pressures to to sustain
the risk to actually do it I think for
the for the time being the United States
for example is trying to kind of buy
some time for diplomacy obviously K
being involved in mediation and and
saying that they're quite confident that
they can get hostages released which is
kind of the number one reason why
Europeans and also the Americans put
some pressure on Israel to delay see
what Hamas can do whether there can be
any negotiations but obviously Israel
can't hold off forever if it actually
wants to achieve its objective of
eradicating Hamas which I think
politically or sorry militarily is
actually impossible if you don't have a
political solution of what's going to
come afterwards Andreas I want to ask
you about a bit more of the strategy
we've been seeing here because Israel
has obviously stepped up its bombing
campaign why the intensity of this
bombardment especially in the South
where people have obviously been told to
flee now if Israel wanted to avoid
civilian casualties and Evacuate the
north as it says why not then stop
bombing in the South and encourage
people to actually go
there well Israel is making the case
Israel is very unprepared for this it's
unprepared militarily it's definitely
unprepared strategically uh it's kind of
operating in the IDF is put in this
impossible place of where it has to
operate in a in a in a place that has no
political strategy where the military
has to now achieve ends that it cannot
achieve through a Warfare but that need
to be achieved politically through
diplomacy negotiation and in this void
of strategy the IDF is trying to kind of
pursue all kinds of targets
understanding that from the air and
remotely you can't really destroy Hamas
all the targets because they're
underground at the same time there is an
indecisiveness among the political
leadership and also leadership of the
IDF whether a ground offensive is really
something that they want to do because
it would shift the burden extensively
not only to the civilian population of
Gaza but also on to Young Israelis who
might die in vain because there is no
political end gain that they can achieve
strategically so it's a very desperate
approach that we're seeing at the moment
and obviously one that Hamas has
prepared for Hamas for the last 17 years
duck the tunnels refortify the defenses
and make themselves almost impenetrable
from from the air Andreas C there a
senior Lector in security studies at
Kings College London always great to get
your thoughts Andreas thank you for
joining us again on Al
jaer